[موسيقى]
هذه
الزيارة إلى براغ مختلفة ،
فالوباء
يفرض وتيرة أبطأ ويوفر
المزيد من الفرص للتعبير عن
[الموسيقى]
هناك الكثير الذي لم أره في
الماضي الرائع والفريد بشكل غريب ،
وهذا هو أضيق زقاق في براغ
إنها ضيقة للغاية يجب أن يكون لها
نظام إشارات المرور الخاص بها
حتى تعرف متى يكون من الآمن الصعود والنزول ،
آه ، حان دوري
ضيق جدًا بحيث لا يكاد عرض الكوعين هو
أحد الأشياء العظيمة في براغ هو
أنك واجهت ما هو غير متوقع
بعد أضيق زقاق أ  طابور طويل
ومجموعة من علب الري ،
ما هو كل شيء عن
[الموسيقى]
آه ، لقد بدأت في رؤية كيف أن بانوراما
براغ تتلاءم معًا
الآن مرة أخرى إلى جسر تشارلز ،
ما هو المقصود بالنهر
والجسر الذي لا ينتهي أبدًا
بالإلهام حتى
بالنسبة له  نحن السكان المحليين عندما تتجول
وتنظر في أي وقت تجد
شيئًا لم تلاحظه
قبل أن
تحصل شركة rodka labance على مهنة من
الانغماس
في الثقافة هنا نلتقي في
الجزء العلوي من
برج الجسر بالنسبة لي هو نوع من الإلهام
ولكنه ليس مصدر إلهام بمعنى أنه مثل
امرأة شابة مما يجعلك
تشعر بالجنون ولكنه يشبه إلى
حد كبير سيدة متطورة
شاهدت الكثير من الأشياء ، من المثير للاهتمام
الجلوس هنا ينظر من النافذة
إنه لمن المسكر أن
ننظر إليه ،
فهناك طبقة من النجوم المائية
والأرضية والسماء ،
لذلك هناك الكثير من السحر المدمج
في الهندسة المعمارية
والعديد من القواعد هنا
يؤمنون بالفعل بالسحر
وتركوا هذا الاعتقاد في المدينة.
من الأساطير والأساطير ،
إنها جزء من البلد ، فلنلقِ نظرة على
wenceslas ،
لذا أعني أنه راعي بلدنا ،
لذلك عندما يكونون أسطورة جنسية ،
هناك ليال مخبأة في
الجبال وعندما تكون الأمة التشيكية في
أسوأ نقطة هم
سوف يخرج ويقوده البزاقة القديس فانس
على حصانه في
محاولة لرسم خيط ذهبي من
خلال مشكلة اليوم إلى
أين يحدث ذلك ، وكيف يمكن أن
تراه على أنه يخدع
كان هناك دائمًا هذا الاختلاط بين
الثقافة والتأثير وأعتقد
أنني شخصياً محظوظ جدًا لأننا
عدنا إلى تلك المرحلة ،
هل عدنا إلى تلك المرحلة وآمل ذلك